hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the tiebreakers of the
champions showdown after the final round
after nine rounds alireza and fabi were
tied for first place and they went into
tie breaks so the tiebreaks are
consisted of two rapid games but not 20
minutes like um
the the usual games are uh they were in
fact 10 minutes per player plus a two
seconds increment and then only if those
two games are tied they go into a blitz
armageddon game so this is the first
game of the
of the rapid tie breaks uh let's check
it out and there is a very important
announcement after we check out the game
so don't uh leave before you hear that
it uh it uh
concerns the
stream we'll be having today it's a
charity stream with the gift of chess
foundation but i will talk a bit more
about that after we check out the game
so alireza has the white pieces and he
opens with ponte b for a great choice in
pretty much any position with knights to
g6 by fabi knight to f3 uh and then now
pawn to f6 he wants to counter the queen
so f6 e5 makes sense we have e4 and pawn
to e5 we have uh c4 by alireza and now
fabi realizes that this could be uh
weakening the white king a bit too much
and he immediately plays a5 he wants to
open up the position and attack the
black the white king the queen will open
maybe the rook can open the bishops are
very nicely placed so it's a it's a
really weird position right
from the beginning and some of you asked
like what's the evaluation of the
starting position in chess 960 well it
uh pretty much differs from game to game
but for let's say for this position it's
a 0.5 for white which is pretty normal
like in in a standard position so
nothing spectacular we have b5 of course
eleazar doesn't want to open up the a
file for fabi's queen and now bishop the
c5 you could also consider bishop to a3
check it seems like a very annoying move
uh
but uh obviously fabi decided that there
was no need for that so bishop c5 we
have d four ball it is a captures
captures and now uh knight to d6 we have
pawn to f3 uh now opening up the the
dark square bishop and the bishop to f7
uh we have queen the c3 uh no longer is
a bishop to a3 now possible as the queen
covers that square we have castles and
this castle really shows how you really
have to pay attention in chess 960 or
you know because here it seems like okay
if the position opens up the the white
king will be vulnerable but also the
black king isn't really enjoying his
time on c8 but here uh just uh king side
castles now it's possible there's
nothing in between and there's nothing
where the king and rook will land so in
chess 960 this makes for a possible
castles and if alireza wants to do this
well he still has to move the uh
a lot of pieces here uh okay the knight
doesn't have to move but the bishops do
have to move so here king to b2 alireza
says he will castle artificially here on
the queen side knights the e5 by fabi
and king to a1 and okay the king does
look
fairly safe there we have bishop to be
for attacking the queen and queen to c1
and here uh we have knight e characters
and c4 fabi just grabs a pawn but it's
important to play uh this knight
captures if you play this knight
captures then f4 is very annoying and
then the knight just um is undefended so
after queen c1 knight e captures and c4
is played and now bishop captures and
see sorry bishop captures on c4 knight
captures on c4 in the now knight to f5 a
most annoying piece
no doubt so pawn to d5 and now bishop to
d4
uh alireza putting a lot of pressure on
on fabi's king side but he also has
problems of his own so bishop to g6 and
now knight h to g3
we have rook beat the e8 and now pawn to
h4 preparing pawn to h5 so here we have
queen to c8 uh and uh here fabi allows a
very very neat trick um for reza to play
if fabi wants uh he should just start
with c5 and bust open the queen side
right away but he first prepares it and
now he gives alireza the chance or
rather the time to go for this knight
captures and g7 move it makes sense as
the bishop is in this diagonal the queen
can come to g5 then uh very very uh hard
to deal with so okay if i plays king
captures on g7 pawn to h5 now and what
do you do here if you if you try to save
the bishop let's say bishop to f7 then
just queen g5 check and the black
resigns after bishop captures on f6
that's uh that's it
of course you cannot capture the pawn is
pinned so this is resigned so after this
h5 move we have knights to e5 by fabi
again c5 is a little bit better you
don't want to waste any time on the king
side uh but there isn't all that much
time for them at the thing so they have
to play 95 with h captures h captures
and now pawn to f4 kicking away fabi's
knight
knight to g4 and now pawn to e5
interestingly pawn to f5 is winning
right away for alireza whereas pawn to
e5 uh is uh
well it does look like the move you want
to play but it's actually this move that
should be played again g5 is impossible
because queen captures on g5 and there
just aren't that many good moves if
knight d5 then just captures and g6 it's
it's looking very very bad for black
knight can now come to f5 to h5 it's uh
it just looks bad
but okay here all it is i played e5 and
now we have finally pawn to c5 fabi says
i have to stop worrying about the king
side it's time to open up the queen side
b captures on c6 alpha the queen
captures and now e captures an f6 with
check we have king to f7 of course
you're not going to capture and allow
this bishop to come alive
although i mean you could but uh will uh
they are humans after all so king f7 and
now queen to b2 alireza declines the
queen trade and he still wants to push
for more than a draw here we have
knights to e3 by fabi uh saying that uh
okay if you if you capture you lose a
very very strong piece and also i will
activate my rook so rook d the c1
attacking the queen here and not knight
c4 uh attacking the the white queen we
have queen to f2 avoiding the queen
trade and now rook to h8
uh we have rooked the h1 opposing the
rook and now knights the a3 attacking
the rook but really going for this
knight to c to check this would just be
devastating if it uh happened so rook h
back to c1 and not knight back to c4 and
here uh uh it is not interested in a
repetition he goes queen to f3
so what do you what do you play here uh
well rook to h4 very nicely very nicely
played by fabi we have knights to f1
knight the e2 is the way to go knight to
f1 is a nice nice attempt but
if rook to e4 then it all just uh falls
apart but again not enough time queen to
d7 by fabi and now we have pawn to g3
yep
defending f4 also attacking the rook
here so rook h3 and now rook to d1 we
have rogue back to c8 queen to g2 now
putting pressure on the rook and the
rook back to h8 we have knight to h2 and
now knight back to a3 again going for
knight to c to check so here knight to
f3 uh threatening knight to e5 check
which would of course win win the queen
and d7 but here just knight to c to
check and here the real question is what
would you play here there are only two
moves possible in the position one of
them being king to b2 and the other one
being queen captures and c2 and now that
of course i've mentioned this you guys
uh are of course uh
uh
interested in playing queen captures on
c2 and not uh maybe because you've
calculated everything but just because
it looks much cooler and this uh
definitely would be the case uh if queen
captures on c2 rook captures on c2 you
then win your queen back knight to the
e5 with czech let's say king e7 knight
captures king captures and let's say f7
attacks the rook rook moves rook to f8
and now uh there are many ways to play
this but basically it's uh it's a it's a
very long force to draw a three or you
want to open up the the b file uh bishop
captures an a3 rook captures and b7 king
or
ryder rook to c7 even better rook to b5
going after the pawn here bishop to b4
with uh
bishop to b4 just defending the a5 pawn
and now bishop to e5 attacking the rook
here also uh adding more firepower to
this if a d5 pawn bishop c3 check
forcing a trade of bishops characters
captures now you're going to capture on
d5 and after let's say king to c6 just
through capture 75 and rook captures on
g3 and you get this position where okay
uh ali is up upon but it's a double
death pawn and
it's just it's just the draw however
after this knight the sea to check
alireza did not play what uh of course
all of you guys wanted to play he played
king to b2 and now he just allows fabia
a very nice
uh finishing move which is very odd as
this is not the only winning move pretty
much all the moves are winning for fabi
like queen to b5 is a winning queen to a
for his winning but bishop to a3 is just
uh mating too so of course this is what
fabi played and he was in this position
on move 37 that alireza furuja resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here once king b3 is played
queen to b5 will be checkmate and that
is of course it
so even though alireza was leading the
entire tournament and this was supposed
to be his uh third win in st louis uh
fabi says nope not gonna happen uh but
even though he wins the first game
alireza retaliates in the second game of
the of the tie breaks and they go into
armageddon where after a very very long
long and tedious grind fabi uh was able
to convert his extra pawn into a win but
after like a hundred moves were played
so it was a quite a brutal game
and in the end fabi was victorious and
fabi is the winner of the uh
champions showdown chess 960
championship
uh so big congratulations to fabi but
also huge congratulations to alireza who
almost won all the events here in saint
louis so it was truly truly spectacular
uh to watch all of them play uh hope to
see more of it soon and uh well now we
now we turn on to other events uh but
yeah i'm also very interested in uh i've
seen some comments in the chat regarding
chess 960 do you enjoy do you don't
enjoy it do you do you really need
opening theory to enjoy chess or can you
just you know give me a position and i i
want to see some moves being played what
are your thoughts about that also
uh and i mentioned that at the beginning
of the of the video that i will be uh
hosting a
charity stream for the gift of chess
foundation so if you guys want to want
to learn more it will be today
at 8 00 pm central european time maybe
not exactly about 8 ish you know we're
going to have a lyches tournament we're
going to have some guests over we're
going to discuss it you guys will be
able to ask questions in the chat uh
we're going to show some nice photos uh
there will be a promotional video that
you guys can enjoy uh so
basically
we're going to be talking about the
education of youth in new york
uh also the
uh uh uh
contributing uh to
some african countries uh regarding
chess sets uh for example they've
already contributed to nigeria to uganda
to kenya and they are uh planning to do
even three more countries and that's
only for the beginning they're also uh
trying to get more chess sets and
education into prisons so there is quite
a lot uh there will be a fundraiser so
if you guys want you will also be able
to contribute to this goal but uh i will
put a link in the description of this
video it will be the first thing you
will see if you guys want to uh
contribute right away but uh as there
will be a stream where you guys will be
able to hear everything and enjoy
maybe even asking a few questions uh
you can also do do it then if you feel
uh that that is something that you you
would enjoy doing
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and it's a very short
coverage of the uh champions showdown if
you have any other game that you
particularly enjoyed feel free to use
the suggestion i know i i will look into
it but if not we are definitely
returning to normal chess
so once again hope you guys enjoyed it
uh hope to see you in the stream today
and i would like to thank paul sertano
jose palacio philippe palacio ysu papaya
in panama and matthew garner and luke
longbone for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day